pas de chance pour michel accary qui
pensaient pouvoir imposer sa tracking rc
18 surtout en l'absence du favori du
championnat de la montagne patrick des
slows forfait pour ennuis mécaniques
mais c'était sans compter sur la pluie
qui désavantage les barquettes comme on
les appelle
sur ce genre de circuit il ya de la boue
sur la route donc là toute la partie
haute et tous les intérieurs où il ya
pas mal de boue donc on va falloir les
éviter on va essayer la déranger du
mieux que possible mais c'est vrai qu'on
a deux montées la sphère qui sont on
part dans l'inconnu et non plus il fait
les affaires des voitures fermées à
quatre roues motrices
plus à l'aise dans les courbes sur sol
mouillé comme rodrigue théodore sur sa
citroën ds3 r 5 qui voit dans cette
opportunité climatique la chance de se
hisser sur les premières places du
classement général on a une opportunité
le fait qu'ils aient de la pluie donc ça
élimine un tout petit peu un certain
type de voiture donc là aujourd'hui
c'est le moment d'essayer de marquer de
gros points après un début de saison
difficile à chercher les bons réglages
le champion de martinique des rallyes
2018 stephen hoffman sur sa nouvelle ds3
r 5 était hier sur le circuit du marigot
en quête de sensations
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est de cet
ajustement de remonter dans l'auto par
rapport à notre
voilà du dernier rallye donc vraiment
confirmé que les réglages soit correcte
des quais ans et puis bon ben on
commence à continuer à apprendre la
voiture tranquillement sur une route
fermée
au terme de cette troisième course de
côte de la saison c'est stephen hoffman
qui s'impose au classement devant
thierry cadet deuxième sur sa mitsubishi
lancer evo6 ont été honorés 3e michel
accary est quatrième les pilotes ont
rendez vous au françois le 12 octobre
pour la prochaine étape du championnat
de la montagne